DAN KOPP: Well, let's talk
about some hurricanes.
So hurricanes,
natural disasters.
They cause a lot of
problems around the world.
One-point-- sorry--
$153.9 billion of damage
in 2016 alone.
No one is immune to
weather emergencies.
Are people prepared?
Whether it's a hurricane,
or it's a tornado,
or it's a flood or a snowstorm,
everybody needs something.
And sometimes people
need a lot of things.
But what do you do?
You go to the grocery store.
The shelves are empty.
You go to your local
hardware store,
and you need a
tarp for your roof,
and they could all be gone.
Empty shelves don't help anyone.
There's a lot of
opportunity around this.
How do organizations
and businesses
change the way they
operate so they can quickly
react to these types of storms
to meet people's basic needs?
Obviously, there's chances
to increase revenue.
There's obviously chances to
lower transportation costs.
A lot of times in
these scenarios,
supply chains get
disrupted, and you end up
paying what's essentially
the same thing
as overnight shipping to get
your product to your stores,
and it costs a lot of money.
And then you also have a chance
to make a real difference
in people's lives,
and you have a chance
to really have a lot of
increased customer loyalty.
You can really win
customers for life
if your organizations
can get this right.
But obviously, it's not easy.
There's a lot of real
world constraints
that come into play here.
You don't have every
product that you
need in every store and
every distribution center.
Like I mentioned, logistics--
the costs are expensive,
and there's often
a very short window of time.
If you're talking about
a tornado or a wildfire,
you'd have hours,
maybe, of notice.
In the case of a
hurricane, maybe you're
lucky enough that you've
got a couple days.
And so an organization has to
be able to react very quickly.
But you also don't
know which products
you need to send, and
then how much, and when.
So that's what we're
going to talk about today.
So quickly, who are we?
We are North Highland.
We are a full spectrum
expertise management consulting
firm, mid-sized, located
in Atlanta, Georgia.
And we go to market across
four different service lines--
customer experience, performance
improvement, tech and digital,
and transformation with
these eight capabilities.
And the three of
us presenting today
are in the data and
analytics capability.
OK, how do you respond to
this as an organization?
That didn't come out right.
So we're talking
about a model today.
We're talking about
a predictive model.
And with any
predictive model, even
if it is the most accurate
model in the world,
somebody has to do
something with that number.
Somebody has to operationalize
it and make it happen.
And for a large
enterprise, there
are many components that
have to be pulled together
to make that happen.
Product prediction, that's what
we're here to talk about today.
But other things, such as
ownership and decision-making.
Who is going to say if that's
the right amount of product
to send to a store?
What approvals have to happen?
Having some kind of
central command, where
people are all in the same
room to make these decisions
very quickly.
All the different trends
and freight issues
around diverting freight
from different locations.
Having contracts in place for
shipping in these situations,
so you're not paying
spot market prices.
Obviously, communication and
visibility is very important.
IT system uptime--
everything runs on a system.
If you can't get
these orders plugged
into some kind of
system, it's not
going to result in a truck roll.
And store ops resilience--
this is a big one.
So if you've got a store out
there, a hurricane just went by
and the roof is ripped
off, how do you know?
Are your people going
to be able to show up?
If they can show up and
your store is intact,
customers are going
to start showing up.
What happens if you only have
some of your employees show up,
or they're home
helping their families?
What if they don't have power?
All these things happen, and so
people need to prepare for it.
And finally,
customer engagement.
If you can do hyper
local communication
with your customers to say which
stores are open, which stores
are closed, what
products do they have,
what products are
they waiting on,
you will definitely resonate
with your customers.
OK, the business case.
There's a lot of
opportunity here.
We looked at a number
of investor calls
throughout the last
number of years,
where there have been
a lot of hurricanes.
And you can see there
are big numbers we're
talking about-- $360 million
of hurricane-related sales
in 2011.
I believe that was
Hurricane Sandy.
Second quote, significant demand
on the transportation system,
and costs went up.
This is the C-suite of
very large companies.
Hurricanes Harvey and
Irma drove demand,
and our team sent over
11,000 truckloads of product
for two storms in two
cities, two states.
To take that one
step further, we'll
talk about the actual
revenue impact.
So this is from the
end of last year,
again, for Irma and
Harvey, different retailers
and the impact it
had on their revenue.
You can see you've got a lot
of home improvement companies
up at the top.
Clearly, they have a
lot of revenue to gain.
And then you've got some others
lower on the bottom there,
where maybe they don't--
such as Macy's and Kohl's--
don't necessarily sell a
lot of generators or tarps
or flashlights and batteries.
But they are impacted
just the same.
Maybe they need to work on
their store ops resilience
or come up with their
transportation plans,
or they need to adjust
those to reduce cost.
But that is not what we really
came to talk about today.
We want to talk about a
little bit of technology.
And here to go
into the prediction
is my colleague, Charlie Morn.
CHARLIE MORN: How did
we make this happen?
How did we build a model that
can effectively predict demand
in near real-time, based on
very confusing situations
on the ground?
Well, Google Cloud
Platform has enough tools
to make a system like
this possible to build.
Everything from a
big data platform,
data warehousing system in
BigQuery and cloud storage,
to the machine
learning tools that
are enabled through Cloud
ML, TensorFlow, scikit-learn
and Keras on top of that,
to orchestration layers
like Kubernetes that lets
you run massive processing
loads at a moment's notice
that can scale up and down
and be efficient in
their processing.
It gives us a very
easily deployable,
maintainable, highly reliable
system that we can work with.
One of the biggest problems
that we had coming in,
and we knew we were
going to run into this,
was getting all
the weather data.
If you don't know where a
storm hit almost exactly,
how can you predict
hyper local demand?
If a hurricane
moves by 50 miles,
you might be sending
generators to the wrong store.
So you need to understand
exactly where demand
is going to be by understanding
what the weather is.
There's a big problem
with that, though.
Turns out when a
hurricane hits, all
of the meters and sensors
that the National Weather
Service has out there fail.
They stop reporting
accurate wind speeds.
total rainfall,
and you just get nulls
in your data set.
Actually, NOAA has a great data
set that's available for free
in Google BigQuery.
We looked into it,
and it turns out
during all of the key
hurricanes that we
were interested in
training on, there
were big old blanks in the data.
But no, it does
provide time forecasts,
and you can get
current hour forecasts
that essentially reflect
the reality on the ground.
But those are in an
interesting file format,
and they can't just be dumped
straight into a database.
So we need a
processing tool that we
can use to get the data
from NOAA into BigQuery.
So how do we do this?
Each file is
programmatically named
based on the time, the
forecast that it's running,
as well as the number of hours
in the future that the forecast
is for, because if something
is happening right now--
sorry about that-- if an
event is happening right now,
we want to be able to understand
the impact in the future
as well.
So we can generate a
URL from the date/time
that we're interested
in predicting,
and download from
NOAA and process
that in-- actually, it's
a Fortran library that has
existed since, I think, 1982.
So we need a
specialized environment
that can run Fortran.
We can't just run this
in a Node App Engine
or something like that.
Then we will dump the
results into a CSV,
and stream those
records into BigQuery.
24 files per day for 10 years
results in about 150 billion
records that we're
having to load in order
to train the model.
So we used Docker and
Kubernetes in this case
to do our deployment strategy.
There are a lot of
different technologies
you could use to do this.
As an organization is moving
into a cloud environment,
they're going to have
guardrails put up.
You have to work within
the constraints that
are set by security and
reality on the ground.
And Kubernetes was
a really good tool
that was in our
allowable toolbox here.
So we developed
Python programs--
two of them, actually--
to just do the quick streaming,
and land in Kubernetes.
Now if you've been to many
talks this conference,
you've probably heard
about Kubernetes.
And most of the talks
are about Kubernetes
as a microservices
handling layer.
You can deploy a bunch of
different microservices
on Kubernetes, and they
will scale up, scale down.
That's actually not
what we're doing here.
We only have two services
in this, and neither of them
are micro.
We're just using Kubernetes
for raw computing power,
and we don't have
to manage anything.
So we have a Redis
Pod that we spun up.
That has a list with all 10,000
files that we want to download.
And we spin up about
500 different computers.
Each processing
task is very small,
so we only need the G1
small compute engine type.
It's very inexpensive,
and we can actually
make those nodes
preemptible as well
to lower the cost even further.
Redis gives us a very fault
tolerant system to work in.
It's very fast.
And this is all the code that
it took to spin up two jobs.
One, on the left, you've
got our Python script
that's going to do the
downloading and processing.
And on the right
is just an example
of how you would spin up
the Kubernetes cluster.
That's pretty much
all the work that we
had to do from the management
and orchestration side.
It saves a lot of time.
It's really clean and
nice to work with,
and you don't have to know
MapReduce, which is also nice.
So Matt's going to come
up in just a second
to talk about the details
of how we do the prediction,
but just to give you an idea
of what we're predicting,
we're looking across 300 product
categories for a retailer.
And we're trying to understand,
what is the change in dollar
demand in that category?
If I want to buy a mop, how
much is the total dollar demand
going to increase?
Well, you might have
multi packs of mops.
You might have single packs of
mops, multi packs of bleach.
So by distilling it
to the dollar level,
you're able to
get a good insight
into what is the actual
consumer need in this area.
How much product
do we need to ship?
And this is a noisy graph,
but I'll explain how it works.
If we look at the way demand
actually works in a store,
the blue line is the
real customer demand.
These are people coming
and knocking on your door
and saying, I want to
buy something from you.
A traditional
replenishment system
is not fast enough to
respond to that demand,
because leading
into an event, you
will have what's
called pre-strike,
where the demand is
increased immediately
before the hurricane comes.
I bet a lot of people
here have gone out
and bought flashlights
or batteries right
before a hurricane is coming
just in case you lose power.
Additionally, you're going
to have a second demand spike
when the event really happens.
And that's the one that's really
hard to respond to and predict.
The yellow line
that you see here
is the amount of
days of stock that
a traditional replenishment
system might leave you with.
Ordinarily, it works well.
It keeps you around.
Whatever baseline you set
for your punishment system,
it keeps about that many
days of stock on hand.
Maybe you get a shipment
every two weeks of mops.
But in these severe
events, that demand
is going to increase
way too quickly,
and you'll very, very
quickly be out of stock.
You won't have what you need on
the shelves for people to buy,
and then you'll have too much.
After the event, your
replenishment system
has caught up, and
now all of a sudden,
you've got two or three
times the inventory
that you want to have on hand.
For mops, this may or
may not be a big deal,
but think about a high
cost item like a generator.
If you ship a pallet of
generators to the wrong store,
you have inventory that you
can't sell in the wrong place
that you may have to ship to
another store that actually
needs it.
But by then it
might be too late.
People aren't buying
generators anymore,
because their power
is turned back on.
And so now you've got
a bunch of extra stock
that you either have to mark
down significantly or send back
to the distribution center
or something like that.
So we looked into how
we can predict this,
and we came up with
a lot of options.
We looked at traditional
time series analysis.
We looked at linear
regressions, things like that.
None of those can handle
the scale and volume of data
that we were considering.
We really needed something
that could be rapidly scaled
up and accurate across the depth
of data that we're looking at.
To give you an insight into
the modeling techniques
that we used, we're going
to bring up Matt Yates, who
is my colleague.
MATT YATES: I had a lot of
energy around this project,
just because the opportunity to
really impact people's lives,
to meet people at
a time of need.
And it was a lot of fun too,
because we got to really
be on the bleeding edge.
Loved interacting and working
with Google Cloud Platform.
This was one of my
first interactions.
So I think that the
two themes that we've
heard about Kubernetes and
about machine learning and AI
at this conference
really continue on,
and we really experienced
the benefits of those things
as we'll go through here.
So just to give you a sense
of what our pipeline looks
like here, we had to build
out a ton of features
in order to be able to give
you an accurate prediction.
So we've got features
in here, and we'll
go into really detail around
what we're doing there.
But we've got Kubernetes
pulling in that weather data.
We've got BigQuery,
which is housing
a lot of internal company data.
We're augmenting
that with census data
and some other really
rich open data sources,
putting those into
models, training them.
TensorFlow and Keras
have a little bit
of scikit-learn in
the pipeline there
as well, the pre-processing.
And then ultimately all
of that gets wrapped up
into an output prediction
So let's deep dive
on some of these.
On the actual features,
weather we knew right away.
We're going to have
to collect that.
We went and got billions of
records, put them in BigQuery,
was able to roll those up into
a store hourly grain in BigQuery
in a matter of minutes.
So you're talking about
terabytes and terabytes
of data, billions of records.
We sort of arranged it into
store using trade areas,
zip codes.
So we needed to go from an
individual weather dot on a map
to a zip code,
assigning it to a store,
and then rolling all of that
up to a store hourly, actual,
or forecasted weather.
And BigQuery handled
it effortlessly.
It was spectacular.
Beyond that we went
out and got NLCD data.
That's National
Land Cover Database.
It's a governmental
agency that publishes--
basically, they go
through satellite imagery,
turn that using some
classification tree
models into information around
what's the tree cover like.
What's the impervious
surface percentage
at any particular
point at a three meter
grain across the US?
They also have a really rich--
I think it was 18
category data set about,
for this point on a map,
is this high urban density,
low urban density?
Is it ice, or is it a farmland?
So some really rich
data around what's
happening on the earth
at a particular point.
And we were able to aggregate
that off at the store level
to say, what percentage
of the store's trade area
is covered by farmland versus
high density urban housing?
And that's going to make
a difference in what sells
ultimately following a storm.
Census data-- widely available.
Population densities pulled in
a lot of really cool information
from the census as
a potential feature.
And then inventory sales
data from our client.
So one thing that I really
wanted to point out here
was we did almost all of
our feature engineering
in BigQuery, and I absolutely
loved working with it.
SQL worked 95% of the time.
We found a couple
of instances where
we wanted to use JavaScript
in a user-defined function.
So I've got a
little example here.
Our project was
beyond hurricanes,
so this is a tornado example.
But it would be pretty
difficult in SQL alone
to, given a latitude-longitude
of a tornado,
find all of the
stores associated
with potential impact from that
tornado, find their distance,
rank the distance.
It takes some pretty complex
geometry, trigonometry.
I had to go back and remember
some stuff from high school
to do this, but I was able to
create a user-defined function,
call that user-defined
function in SQL,
and create some really
complex calculations
right on top of the query.
Very fun stuff.
So then once we did our
feature engineering,
we needed to train those models.
We went in here thinking
we could sort of create
one model to rule them all.
So we're thinking RNNs.
We have some time series.
We're thinking multi-output.
So we have all these
product categories.
Let's predict them
all in a single model.
We experimented with that.
We were able to get
a skillful model.
It was about twice
as good as a naive
model of just a moving average.
So if a moving
average model said
you'd have $200 worth of cells,
we might be $200 off for that.
And our model with our RNN
was able to predict that
twice as well.
But we weren't
satisfied with that.
We thought, we can do
better if we dissect
the problem a little more.
So ultimately, we
ended up creating
just a sequential
feedforward neural network
and actually dividing
it from multi-output
down to a single
output, and then
just creating a lot of
those little deep networks
and calling them individually.
And when we create
the prediction,
we can call each of those
models individually in serial
or parallel, and
we're able to make
those predictions for
each product category
using a similarly
architected neural network,
but with the discrete weights.
So initially, we're
using TensorFlow.
We were feeding the data
in with a queue runner,
because with RNNs, you've
got pretty complex data sets,
very big data sets.
Ultimately, we
found if we wanted
to try and make this as
skillful as possible,
let's try to iterate fast.
So in comes Keras.
We're able to iterate and
try things out in Keras.
It's fully compatible with
ML Engine, which we'll
talk about here in a second.
So we moved from pure
TensorFlow to a Keras library
on top of that with
a TensorFlow back end
to do some rapid prototyping.
And the way that we sort of
reframed the problem here
is instead of trying to do an
RNN and a time series analysis,
we said, every one
of these events
has a time zero when the
event actually happened.
We need to go figure out
what our baseline sales were
in the days coming up to that.
We need to figure out what
our pre-strike sales are,
if that's applicable.
And that's something we
might want to predict.
And we would also predict
our post-strike sales.
And the good news is
with a weather forecast,
if I trust the forecast
of the weather,
and I'm not trying to--
we weren't trying to
forecast the weather.
We were consuming that from
NOAA, the National Oceanic
Atmospheric Administration.
I can actually, days ahead of
a hurricane actually hitting,
I can give you, according to
the weather forecast, where's
that hurricane going to hit,
and go ahead and predict
the post-strike demand
right after that.
And then we pooled
the time together,
so instead of trying to do a
time series demand forecast,
we said, let's take
all the demand that's
going to happen in the immediate
period following the hurricane,
lump it all together, and
say, after this hurricane,
here's going to be
your demand level.
And it's going to be
spread out across time,
but we kind of divorced the
time element from our problem.
We were able to get a more
skillful model that way.
So then once we got our
architecture how we wanted it,
we used Hyperparameter
Tuning in ML Engine,
another brilliant
feature of Google Cloud.
And so here, we were
able to tune and sort
of grid search our batch
size, learning rate,
number of layers, the shape
and size of our layers,
and our activation
function to find
the optimal, most
skillful set of those
to make our predictions.
So here is a slide that
we're really proud of.
So as we said, we have 300
different product categories.
The product categories are
really based on consumer needs,
so mops are a category.
Dehumidifiers are
a category, where
you've got a lot of products
that a retailer might
have within each category.
But we're predicting demand for
mops, demand for dehumidifiers.
And in the end, for our
post-storm predictions,
we were able to get
90% of our predictions
within $150 daily average error,
and that's based on hold-outs.
Meaning if we predict
it's going to be
$300 in sales, 68%
of the time, it's
going to be between
$250 and $350.
So pretty accurate there.
We were really pleased.
Our client was really
pleased with the accuracy
on the hold-out set.
And I think that's a function
of a lot of time spent
in feature engineering,
data pipelining,
as well as the power of
deep neural networks.
And then ultimately, I think one
of the major challenges here--
and you'll hear about
it in all of the DevOps
for ML conversations--
is actually getting this
deployed and operationalized.
Ultimately, this is
sort of a structure
we think is the best to keep
this going on a long term using
Container Registry, Kubernetes,
obviously source control.
BigQuery is where
all that data lives.
And then we stored
out all of our models
in Keras in h5 format
to cloud storage.
We were able to call those
back and make those predictions
in, really, almost real time.
I mean each prediction
takes seconds to make,
and the interaction
from cloud storage
and BigQuery and your
compute environment
is really seamless there.
So I'm going to
call Dan back up.
He's going to talk about how
we take these predictions
and actually make them
operationalized on the ground.
DAN KOPP: Thank you, Matt.
OK, so we've got a very
accurate model now.
It's putting out numbers
that we believe in
and that we're ready
to take action on.
So back to my point
earlier, great.
How do you fold this back in?
What do you do with it?
A lot of things have
to happen, still.
First of all, the person still
has to be in the loop here.
Like any model, this
is a prediction.
It has a confidence to it.
And the confidence
can be high or low.
So somebody needs to
say, this one's wrong.
We need to change it.
There's also other factors
that come into play.
Maybe the prediction
is right on,
but the DC doesn't
have the inventory,
or there is an event coming
up at the store next month,
and they don't want to sell
all the inventory this month.
A lot of other factors
that come into play.
The model doesn't
know everything.
A person has got to be involved.
And then once the
person approves it,
it's got to get out the door.
So it's things like, how do
you fit it into your ERP system
to cut a purchase order?
And how do you then
get it on a truck?
You might be shipping-- your
company might use pallets,
or you might use cartons.
How do you get the right number
into those units and on a truck
and out the door?
There's a lot of rounding that
goes on in these scenarios.
So I thought I would
walk through an example.
Again, all of this
is done in BigQuery.
So say, like we mentioned
before, we're doing sales
at a category or grouping level.
In this case, I'll
use generators.
So let's say first
store, we know
that we're going to need
$10,000 in generators.
And we say that, because
we don't necessarily
know if it's this particular
generator that people really
want to buy or that one.
At the end of the
day, people will often
buy whatever generator is
there if their power is out.
And so we predict
at the group level.
But we ship at the item level.
And so we've got to get
this down to an item.
And there's lots
of ways to do this.
To turn this into
an individual SKU,
you can do a number of things.
It depends on your organization.
So maybe you want
to default to what
that store's customers prefer.
Maybe they really love
the 5,500 watt generator.
Or maybe we're talking about
another category-- say,
shingles--
where in this part
of the country,
they really like
architectural gray shingles.
But in another part of country,
they like tan shingles.
And so you really have to
be able to fine tune which
actual products you're
going to send to the store.
Obviously, you have to
check the store's inventory.
Maybe the store has
everything you need,
and you don't need
to ship a thing.
So again, we're talking about
BigQuery taking this prediction
and going in real time,
checking store inventory.
Maybe they don't have enough,
but there's a truck on the way.
You've got to know
that too, obviously.
Maybe even after that,
you still need some,
and so you have to see
if your DC has enough.
Maybe your DC has
enough for your store,
but doesn't have enough for all
the stores that that DC serves.
What do you do in that case?
And then let's say
you figure that out.
You've still get to
round for, how many
do you put on a pallet?
How many pallets do
you put on a truck?
Maybe the recommendation
is you need--
what did we say here--
you need two pallets
of the 5,500 watt.
Well, maybe that was 1.9
pallets that you really needed.
You're probably going
to round that to two.
You're not going to
slow the truck down.
You're not going to slow this
process down to get that right.
You're going to move and go.
So how do you handle
that logic very quickly?
Supply chain organizations
do this stuff all the time,
and the more we can help
them get there faster,
the faster this
whole process works.
And so you see, at the end here,
the net SKU sales prediction
ends up being significantly
different than what
came out of the model.
And so just to talk
about data volume here,
imagine for a large company,
the size of the table that
has the SKU store inventory.
Think of the same
thing for DC inventory.
Think of the same thing for POs.
You've got to hit
billion row tables
over and over and over again,
and you've got to do it fast.
And BigQuery was, again,
pretty awesome at doing it.
Again, so I'm on the,
how do you operationalize
this, notion here.
So you take a model
that's complex,
and we didn't build this
to run this forever.
We built this to hand
over to our client.
And so they often
have a varying range
of skill sets and knowledge
about data science
to where you've got to tailor
your solution to the people who
are going to receive it.
Also, there's a
complexity issue here.
We could probably get the
90% accuracy up to 95%
or higher, if we baked
every single thing
we could in the model, took
everything into consideration.
But then we risk it being
so unwieldy and cumbersome
that nobody would even remember
what all these configuration
parameters were.
And so we had to right-size it.
And so these are
just some examples.
And so these are some of
the tunable parameters.
We call them knobs.
We gave them a lot of knobs
to turn of how they can say,
you know what?
I want to adjust this.
I want to adjust that.
Give them the right
level of granular control
without having to crack open the
code and get their hands dirty.
They can do that if they want,
but if they don't, they've
got a very easy way to
say, last shipment we sent,
it was a little too much, or
it was a little too little.
Let's make some changes.
So you see some things like
max wind gust threshold.
Maybe there are some events
where we didn't really
recommend anything,
because we said
they didn't hit a threshold.
Well, we could maybe
lower that number,
and more events will pop up.
And with that, I'm
going to pass it
back to my colleague,
Mr. Matt, who's
going to show you some demos.
MATT YATES: So ultimately,
what we're going to demo
here is the end
user interface just
so you can get an idea of how
this would be done in action.
Most of these
numbers are made up,
so they don't tie out completely
just for client confidentiality
purposes.
But this will give you an
idea of what we're looking at.
We decided to use
Tableau for these demos.
Love looking at-- working
with Tableau for just
a quick dashboarding tool.
And so we're giving
a sense of both.
How do you look at weather
data and understand
what's happening on
the ground at a store?
How do you turn your weather
data into predictions?
And how should you
consume that as a user?
Ultimately, after you turn
those predictions into orders,
how do you track it?
So what you're looking
at here is the weather
aggregated to a store level.
This is actually for
Hurricane Irma, I believe.
So you'll see all the stores
listed there on the map.
If you click on a store, you
can get a data table here
that shows over time,
some key weather metrics.
So in this circumstance, wind
gust here was 119 miles an hour
on September 12 at noon.
For one of the Florida Keys,
that was the actual wind speed.
We've got a suite of metrics
here from total precipitation,
temperature, vegetation
rates, soil moisture
that you could actually
go through and look
at and understand
what was happening
on the ground at each store.
So I'll play this for
you, and you can actually
see the wind gust
go up the coast.
And it's on loop here, so you'll
see it repeating over and over.
And that is all
wind gusts that we
would consider to
be an event that we
may need to consider potential
demand spikes because
of those events.
So then once you know
that, you want to turn that
into your prediction.
So what you're looking at here
is the actual event prediction
for an Irma example--
154 stores.
I'm going to drill into
a single store here.
And we'll look at,
for the products that
are affected for this
store, the baseline sales
that we would have expected
without an event, 146,000,
we think we're going to get
across all these product
categories, $310,000
worth of sales.
We only have $135,000 on hand.
We've got $33,000 en route.
Therefore, we need to order
$209,000 worth of product.
That's $209,000
aggregate product,
but it's split across
a ton of item classes.
So let's drill into some
of these item classes
and see what we need to order.
For ACs and fans, we need
to order $95,000 there.
You can see we need 38 pallets,
and our mean prediction error
there is plus or
minus one pallet.
So if I'm a merchant, and I want
to be conservative about it,
maybe I'll just
subtract a pallet.
Maybe I'll add a pallet.
Same thing for tarps here.
Our prediction error is
really good, zero on tarps.
On grills, not quite as
good, so we need 21 pallets,
and that's plus or minus two.
And then let's drill in here
on air quality dehumidifiers.
So we need to send three of
those pallets, plus or minus
zero on average, so
pretty good prediction.
So the store typically
sells this 30 watt version
of that, 31% of the time.
But then in emergencies, you
typically send a 50 watt.
So we let the client
choose, do you
want to send 30 watt, which is
typically sold in that store,
or do you want to
send the 50 watt?
So I'm not going to go into
the actual ordering process
here, just for
confidentiality purposes.
But then ultimately,
we turned those,
how many do you need to
order, into an order form
that they could execute
on their system.
Then once you execute
that order form,
you want to be able
to track that data
and track those orders
all the way to a store.
So we built another dashboard
that utilized all of the orders
after they were placed
all the way up until they
were delivered.
So some examples here
of, you can drill in,
just like you can on the
other Tableau dashboard
we just saw, into a
particular product category
for a particular store,
and see exactly what's
headed to that store in both
retail dollars and units.
This could be used by the
merchandising organization,
or it could be used by
the store to understand
what's on its way.
And with the delivery
ETAs and everything else
right there on the page.
So wrap this up.
Machine learning plus a
really deep understanding
of integration with
business process
made this a successful project.
Ultimately, I think
a lot of you guys,
probably not in
the same category,
but there's something to be
considered here for the ability
of how can you react
and appropriately
respond to human emergencies,
whatever they may be,
and help people and change
people's lives for the better.
So really appreciate your
time listening today.
We'll hang out over
here in the corner,
if you want to
ask any questions.
And that concludes
our presentation.